the metaphor is somewhat worn out
nonetheless valid ancient Iraq I'm as
is one of the cradles of civilization
sites in Iraqi South such as oral and
org were the first cities in human
history and the birthplace of writing
and in northern Iraq sites at sites such
as nimrood and many of the
archaeologists uncovered the capitals of
what was probably the first empire in
world history is Syria with palaces and
temples that have produced some of the
most spectacular works of art from
antiquity some of the pieces as you all
know policy in London not in this house
here but in the British Museum and many
way has also produced the first
universal library in human history the
Iraqi sites as we have heard in the
previous communication by dr. Curtis
have actually been pretty well-protected
were other safe in the years between the
1920s and 1980 or 1919 since then
however due to war and political chaos
they have suffered quite extensively and
have seen a lot of illicit digging
especially after the us-led invasion in
2003 much of this illicit digging
however was concentrated in the south of
Iraq such as at the side of omagh which
you can see here whereas the north the
region around Mosul was in fact mostly
affected not so much by deliberate
destruction or digging but simply by
neglect you see here on this slide from
2001 cinakisz palace at Nineveh with the
tin rule that protected it actually
removed exposing sculpture like that to
the weather but in recent years the
situation had actually improved enabling
members of the University of Mosul to
engage in new excavations at many ways
such as the ones documented on that
slide here which were undertaken between
2010 and 2012 now as we've heard before
on jun 10 2014 the islamic state or Isis
invaded the city took the city of Mosul
and brought all these hopeful
developments to an abrupt stop it
immediately are closed down the most
museums owning it into an administrative
center to administer these account tax
it closed down most university
departments forcing academics to flee
the city and to reassemble in our bills
especially Doe who quite kind of assets
university was created it also engaged
in humanitarian acts that are deplorable
I won't talk about them but obviously
they are major concern as well and they
started a campaign of cultural cleansing
that was initially directed mostly
against Islamic and to lesser degree
Christian sites such as in this kind of
a there was a key moment on on july
twenty four 2014 the explosion of the
mosque of the prophet Jonah or you knows
episode of Navy which was actually not a
Shiite side it was actually this is a
Sunni side which shows the degree of
radicalism that the organization is
plays a video released on februari 25
2015 has now shown us or the first one
to show us that the destructive
activities were not just geared against
Islamic crystalloid also against
pre-islamic sites the video showed
distractions in two areas the Naga gate
area at Nineveh in the north of the city
where a wing bull was attacked with with
a drill and several other bulls I won't
show you this we won't show you the
video just so you couple of stills were
were massively damaged and secondly at
the aforementioned Mosul museum where a
number of Syrian slaps were apparently
destroyed but more importantly statues
of deities and Kings from the ancient
city of haha posts are inside from the
Roman pasion period that were destroyed
were toppled and then essentially
destroyed through the use of
sledgehammers
some blog posts have have claimed that
these distractions happen actually
already last summer but to information
that I received from a source in Mosul
it actually happened briefly before the
video on in February was released
obviously or information on these acts
and and other acts still very
provisional there are no independent
journalists or scholars really on the
ground may be careful what we are saying
here but the overall picture that
emerges becomes increasingly clear and
it is quite obvious that in the
aftermath of the destruction of Mosul at
minute II other sides were likewise
attacked by Isis they but before I say
that I should just briefly mention one
problem with the Mosul museum is that we
do not actually know exactly which
artifacts were a house there I show you
two objects here this assyrian arm
sculpture from the reign of Sauron the
second and this sarcophagus from one of
the Assyrians tombs from nimrood that
were housed once in nimrood and it isn't
entirely clear whether they were
evacuated to baghdad in 2003 or worse
still capped in the most museum so one
problem we're facing is that we have not
enough information about what author in
the nozzle museum on march 5th
information was released by isis and not
not yet by Isis but but actually by
independent sources about the
destruction the partly destruction of
the side of nimrood another serene
capital this was not rigidly documented
and the extent of the damage remained
unclear in the aforementioned video
though released just last Saturday on
april eleventh it became clear that
presumably a few weeks later when in
route in fact was more or less
obliterated at least the site of the
palace of a show not see Power which is
particularly deplorable because this was
in fact the
the assyrian palace that was in a way
visible on the ground and after
apparently some slices of reliefs had
been taken away by Isis they simply
detonated this side of which in fact
nothing is left arm information from
march sixth claimed that the site of
haka was likewise massively damaged
original reports were about explosions
having been heard the video released on
April fourth doesn't show the dynamiting
of the very remarkable templates at that
site but it does show attacks on
sculpture such as this hat here and that
decides likewise probably massively
affected finally there were also reports
released on march eight about a
distraction at hows about the last the
third last great surrey capital from the
late eighth century BCE those reports
have not yet been independently verified
or not documented in any way so we know
what the situation at horse about is we
should think about the motivation behind
these acts I think they have to do it
and I think what sets these activities
in this area aside from previous
assaults on cultural heritage sites is
that these are deliberate acts widely
broadcast by Isis through propaganda
videos and other posts on the internet
and I think we can essentially
distinguish three basic audiences that
Isis wants to target through these
actions the first is sympathizers and
potential sympathizers both unreleased
and in the West to whom the organization
wants to show that it faithfully we in
acts iconoclastic acts ascribed in some
traditions to Abraham o Ibrahim and
Prophet Muhammad the second audience is
the people of Syria and Iraq during the
rule of the Assad and Saddam Hussein
attempts were made by
the government of these states to create
an identity across religion sects and
ethnic groups by emphasizing the
greatness of the pre-islamic
civilizations of these we have heard
about that in a negative on Asus
presentation and this kind of nation
building is of course anathema to Isis
with its idea of a caliphate so this is
another audience that's targeted with
these videos and finally the videos are
also addressed so to speak to ask the
people in the West I season deliberately
also inflict pain on the West anyway
which has of course always considered
inch mesopotamias also as part of its
own cultural heritage and is heavily
subsidized and supported archaeological
work in all these places what will the
future bring that's of course very hard
to say at this point the most
spectacular monuments on the ground in a
most a region from the Assyrian period
essentially destroyed of course it is
possible that we will see more looting
and as this golden crown from one of the
Queen's tombs in Mosul shows this would
be extremely catastrophic if if if these
sites were in fact further looted other
sites might also be targeted one
possible type might be uh sure but it
should be said that there is no
monumental arteta sure and so it seems
less of a likely target and promising
target than some of these other places
what can be done this will be addressed
later let me just say very few things
essentially reiterating what has been
said before obviously as long as Isis is
in control of large parts of northern
Iraq and Syria very little can actually
be done it's to be hoped that national
governments such as the Turkish
government is encouraged to better
police its borders to curve the illicit
expectation of Antiquities whether it is
high on the list of priorities or
politicians of course it's very much the
question can we hope so we need to
continue documenting this
action that I think is vital and
probably most importantly we have to
somehow support our colleagues from
Syria and from Iraq the best we can
because they will be the ones who will
be able to return one day to these
places and to start the work that needs
to be done at some point to to do
whatever can be done I believe that
resolutions public resolutions in the
West it will actually not have any
impact will actually be probably rather
counterproductive since Isis
deliberately breaks taboos would only
motivate its supporters to engage in
additional acts of destruction and
finally since I'm speaking here as a
scholar and factors is as an
archaeologist interested in in texts I
should say that as scholars we are
facing of course a major dilemma which
we go to the looting which we all
deplore because the lost contacts is a
catastrophe for ability to reconstruct
ancient history but we also face no
volume of looting that is probably
unprecedented and I do believe that
somehow these looted objects need to be
documented but I think we have to
somehow detach the issue of
documentation from the issue of property
property and ownership however
problematic in legal terms that that may
be thank you very much